le cercle de danse la pierre angulaire
de cette grande fête autochtone
150 danseurs sont réunis cette fin de
semaine pour partager et célébrer leur
identité culturelle et spirituelle aux
parois international de ouenza crise est
finie charles dance d'enfants ça
représente un peu comme un papillon un
oiseau qui s'envole on est heureux nous
en date on vient ici ou un bac es mais
il y en a plein d'autres qui viennent de
partout même des états unis des fois le
les plantations sont la danse du
paraguay invite autochtones et
allochtones à s'unir dans les grands
cercles on vient d'un mode de vie
circulaire comparativement aux européens
quand sont arrivés qui était dans un
mode de vie linéaire donc le cercle est
important dans chacune des premières
nations
c'est un moment où est ce que chaque
nation qui vient on se rend compte qu'on
se partage des moments
expositions ateliers et qu'est-ce que
d'artisanat complète l'expérience pour
le plus grand plaisir des visiteurs
une fois n'apprennent pas limite de zone
de police fait que c'est le fun de voir
beaucoup de monde venu pour s'amuser
pour voir
notre culture je voulais la faire
connaître mais enfin bon la tradition
ancestrale du para one est une
invitation à la paix et à la réflexion
pour les générations futures
servons-nous du passé pour regarder ce
qui est arrivé mais regardons dans
l'avenir pour les prochaines générations
comment on peux se côtoyer comment on
peut avancer ensemble malgré tous les
évènements qui sont pas si on a quand
même réussi à garder ce pia elle se la
prendre aux générations plus jeunes
aussi c'est vraiment rire c'est beaucoup
des bourses seront remises aux meilleurs
danseurs le public est d'ailleurs invité
à voter pour son coup de coeur ici
alicia chevrier radio canada wind acquis